vous seriez m'accorder cette danse une
fois
attention la marche
quelle chaleur 1 dans ce bazar
oui fife les chevaux
dans vacances
non un congé congé convalescent
le choeur annoncé la tête parce que je
comprends
bien et vous je suis en permission de
détente
qui vous a permis dans ce ma femme dit
n'ayez pas peur que soir monde où ça
pourra pas aller bien loin ça pourra pas
les miens c'est ma femme qui ont les
clés de la voiture
dette belge où ça c'est sûr ça s'entend
pas tellement des bleus à peine vous
êtes marié avec une belle chance de mon
lambèse et les jolis noms on vient une
grosse slip
et comme elle porte toujours des savons
je l'entends revenir de loin
rajab
je suis chasseur d'éléphants en
centrafrique et avant j'étais chasseur
de papillons mais comme j'ai cassé mes
lunettes alors
sa marche
vers la ville dense là bas
avec ses cheveux longs qui descendent
jusqu'aux un
superbe oui c'est mon frère
la prochain de notre règle je pile des
choses
barcia des documents et quoi dans le
ciel ya des étoiles
70 millions d'années-lumière de moore
et elles ont moins d'importance pour moi
les étoiles que voulez vous
qu'ils ne sont qu'à 20 cm de myennes à
10 cm
ainsi à 4 à 3 à 2
cinétoiles en forme d'aile
dit entre gifla
ça m'a redonné des couleurs
excusez moi ma cheville c'est un peu
femme à votre tête vous
câline maintenant ça marche
parlez-moi de vie meert en cela je
l'attendais celle-là savait qu il a une
drôle d'affairé dit merckx 1 avec un
coureur français
ils ont été punis les deux coureurs 1 le
coureur français pour cette a tranché
derriere 13 et 10 pour avoir remonté le
même drame
dans tabou dans ses pédales et passionné
il a dans ce sprint prenez pas les
épaules pour un guide
santé oms parlons pas ma note française
alors je vais suivre
ça s'entend pas demandé surtout que je
suis de l'autre
suisse
ça commence bien les nattes
tiens j'ai divorcé
il épouse